Wow that was like a legit squeaky sound
I I could I couldn't even find that
sound effect anywhere we're gonna have
to film that sound effect let's make
that be the intro welcome back to the
6th annual Halloween special I am once
again sitting here with a great friend
of mine Joe Joe Moreno is a fucking
incredible writer and one of the best
note givers I know seriously like you
have some of the best advice whenever I
have anything you're there and you're
just so fucking talented and I love you
I love you too buddy I love you too I
also love you you love me I do okay I
love you almost as much as I hate this
movie no I hate this movie more than I
love you like officially this film I
figured if we're gonna do a bunch of
Halloween movies and a bunch of scary
films and horror films and have my
friends involved with the videos at some
point in time one of my friends is going
to have to sit through a really bad one
because I can't do all of these without
wanting to do at least one hilarious any
mannose hands of fate came out in 1966
this also serves as the pre 1970s review
of the month as I have been doing all
year I have been requested to do this
review for a long time especially on
patreon a lot of great people on patreon
I've asked me to do this review and so
Joe and I we sacrificed ourselves today
before the altar of Manos can let's have
a movie this is half the movie this in
the middle of a cut let's talk about
cuts because this movie wasn't which
there were non-existent they don't exist
in this movie there was no editing no
it's honestly painful the level of
adequate everything that this movie
represents for filmmaking in general
absolutely yeah I honestly just I don't
even have words for how horrified I was
at certain moments was just like you
could tell the actors were almost in
there like it's a camera still it's
camera still on there were parts where
they looked into the lens yeah
especially the kissing couple the
kissing couple I mean like it's just a
constant thing where like every few
moments through back to this kiss couple
and the cop comes up the the pointless
cops come up to ask them what they're
doing the guy's got a wedding ring on
like the yeah it's like they just it's
almost like they just grab some people
off the street was like hey you want to
make out and be in a movie it's gonna be
Hollywood magic it's gonna be great
we're gonna make millions and it's just
you and I've watched a lot of shit you
more than me
yes I'm not used to this level like I
could I was I looked over to you every
what's wrong you're like you're you seem
like yeah I've seen this before I'm just
like no this is completely out of my
realm of expertise I'm slightly
disturbed and that's the end of the
video
no I force myself to watch a lot of crap
our buddy flick dick you know like we
sit down sometimes and he's like why did
you watch spice world and I'm like why
wouldn't you watch spice world there's
more the question is exactly exactly Joe
you get me know like we sat there
watching this film kind of basically
flabbergasted at the complete
incompetence on display at every two
seconds I guess if you want to talk
about the plot would you like to try to
sum it up no no I'm good I'm good I'm
letting you take this one okay I'm just
gonna watch it just slightly look at it
and a bemused expression so there's a
couple Michael is the husband he's very
important you know why cuz he's a man
he's the director and he's also the
director and the writer and the producer
and probably the editor and everything
Tommy Wiseau of the 1960s version
absolutely I mean this guy makes Tommy
Wiseau look like a genius to be honest
like the room is actually a real movie
like it has scenes
with lines that are said and people
answer those lines and typically you
don't have characters standing there
going cameras still going no yes
we're just gonna stand here until they
say cut which it barely never happened I
don't think the word cut was ever said
in this movie in the filming of this
movie I think you can actually see him
mouth the word cut at some point like
cut but without the dialogue and it's
just in the film which is why we have
the Dubs that we do the glorious
glorious dubs
think we're doing something wrong well
whatever it is you're not doing go don't
do it somewhere else why don't you guys
leave it alone you talk about the room
and you see Tommy Wiseau doing his dubs
and everything it at least feels
slightly more like there was some effort
behind it like after you see movie like
the disaster artist you can kind of
respect Tommy Wiseau for at least going
out there and trying there's very little
I respect about this but it is funny it
is very funny to watch especially Torgo
that's happy that for another 30 minutes
that's what the director said
[Music]
don't you ever try that again you bit
master wants you but he can't have you I
want you that's really honestly a large
majority of the movie you got this guy
Torgo who's like the the caregiver or
the the gatekeeper to this cult where
this guy and these women who are his
wives apparently worship this God called
Manos and they apparently make
sacrifices but probably without
exaggerating 15 minutes this movie is
nothing but people going we can't kill a
child
yeah that child must die the child will
become a woman
but the child must die but the child
would become a woman and we are women
there
[Music]
way then you have to have the random
like blood splatter I know it's like
people die in this movie from being
slapped like there's a guy like tour
goes on the the altar or whatever
because he failed and they're gonna
sacrifice salmon and they're literally
they're just fucking lightly slapping
importantly and it keeps cutting to him
and he's like oh did you read up at all
about this actor who portrayed Torgo um
no apparently from sources involved with
the production production he was on LSD
that makes so much more sense really
guys it really dives cuz he is like this
overly erratic and he's got like these
oversized knees like they say stuff
pillows and his knees for some reason
it's Igor but it's not happy that's
basically probably what they were going
for yeah you'd have to yeah there's no
other reason go hey you're gonna wobble
around our set looking slightly dazed as
you randomly touch people's hair
inappropriately both of us were
expecting this to be pretty bad from the
beginning like we knew like generally
that this is considered an awful film
and Mystery Science Theater kind of
popularized it in the 90s but I really
wasn't prepared for like I guess the
editing really know the music I wasn't
ready for the music I wasn't ready for
the editing I wasn't ready for the not
acting I wasn't ready for the cops I
wasn't ready for the kissing couple and
I wasn't ready for the child that is
obviously a woman in really bad falsetto
there were a lot of things I was not
prepared for the dub boys here the dub
forces I think are my favorite thing
wrong out of this like it was three
people right three people who were
brought in in post it'll hey do the
voices for every character
she'll randomly be seen characters
talking there's no dialogue there's no
sound when the cars go on or cars go off
when the car engine breaks down it
sounds like an underwater bubble of some
sort I'm not sure that's all it sounded
like I mean it was probably a guy with
his mouth just going like for the
character of Mike the the movie is like
a series of sequences where he
becomes out of commission he runs
outside he's like what's going on what's
notice is out here and there's nothing
but the dogs dead and then he walks back
inside and the girl dogs dead the dogs
dead he's holding a gun like his
family's daughters like right there and
he's like I don't know this this dog is
dead and he's just like flailing this
gun around right in front of his small
child that's the fucking beginning of
the movie but then he gets knocked out
in a great scene yes a really wonderful
stunt okay like no joke
Torgo tying him up to that tree was
probably about a minute and a half long
yes
that was painful because you're waiting
for the cut editor leave the cuts not
gonna come is it
no you're gonna stand here for a minute
while we finish it I do a tree this
feels like a movie that was made just
because somebody the director was like
I'm gonna make a movie in fact
apparently he made a bet with another
writer that he couldn't make a film that
was in some way popular and he's wrong I
guess the other guy was wrong yeah this
is called classic status
we're here in 2018 talking about it so
something clearly happened for him you
mentioned earlier that that I tend to
watch more crappy films than you which
you know is totally true and I'm guilty
part of it for me is that I tend to
sometimes actually get more inspired
when I see what not to do and I'm
curious for someone like you when you
watch a film like this is it just
creatively deadening like is it just
avoid or are you in some way like hey
that guy got it done maybe I can get
myself moving it depends on where you
want to be creatively I mean you can
look at anything and find some sort of
inspiration from it it just depends on
okay are you I mean I think that there
are two different thoughts before there
are people that they are particularly
inspired by going this is everything I'm
not gonna do I'm gonna make sure almost
out of spite
I'm gonna make sure I'm better than that
there's other people who look at
something great like all the work
of Hitchcock Spielberg Scorsese I'm
gonna be that so I think it depends on
where you're starting from yeah I mean
for me personally I'm more inspired by
what I want to be or what I want to do
but something like this is incredible
for showing you issues that you might
not know are a facet like I've never
seen bad editing I could see I mean this
I mean yes bad edges are atrocious
editing this isn't real editing there's
they basically just wide the shots in
chronological order they just I think
for this that one tip okay now I know
what can go wrong with editing I know
what can go wrong with dubbing I know
what can go wrong with hiring people on
LSD no you you now have a framework to
build out going yeah that thing we're
not going to do that
I think that's honestly as I watch the
film and then you know I read up into
the production it seemed like that's
what he was figuring out but as he made
it like oh shit this isn't how you do it
and then editing oh crap this isn't how
you make a movie but it's too late
because he made it I never thought I
would look at a film and good I think
what during the movie you even went ed
woods better than this yeah that's true
they plan 9 was better and that's just
such a scary thought to contemplate that
a movie makes that look competent it
does yeah
it is frightening to really think about
what can be done when you when you get a
group of people together who are just
not ready for this in but this is the
type of film that gets made when you
have that type of mentality like oh I
can make a movie of Hollywood magic it's
perfect yeah because great directors
make it look easy great actors make it
look easy until you're there trying to
actually do it you realize how hard it
really is I did read something about the
film where they said a lot of the issues
that people were having with the film
while it was being made they said well
don't worry about it we'll fix it in
post
well things in a post post will fix
everything another thing that you you
know you don't know until you get there
wait no matter we film this entire movie
by that it's too late your start
what you got definitely so I don't know
Amanda this way it was it was a it was
an experience thank you for taking this
ride with me I'm going to I'm going to
cry myself to sleep tonight I'll be
there right with you I'll be randomly
waking up in the mill night that would
just be this guy just like that'll be me
in you you're gonna buy the red cloak
right now okay I'm directly yeah Amazon
Prime ship it to my house I'll be at
Joe's house tonight
we must kill this child you are
troublemaker you deserve to die die I
may die but I do not care the child must
live what did you feel you got out of
this in regards to like how what does it
make me feel like as I like someone who
wants to create yeah I think it gets me
excited to talk about it which there is
something to be said about what films
like this or the room or troll to do to
people like you and I like it it does
make us want to talk about it absolutely
and there is something something there
to ponder about you know like as I you
and I stood outside of a theatre with
John Rodriquez talking about
annihilation for half an hour you know
but that's a different type of thing
like that was like wow this is different
wow this is Wow yeah this is Wow
but still there is something to be said
about movies like this and plan 9 where
it kind of makes people who want to be
creative and want to create not just
think like I want to never do that again
but there is something about the idea of
some random guy who has nothing in
Hollywood who has has no real talented
about making films who just says hey I'm
gonna do it and does it and now you know
all these years later we're sitting
there talking about it
and so you have to wonder similar to
Tommy Wiseau in the room you have to
wonder despite the complete failure of
this movie was it anything that brings
entertainment or joy to people can't be
a complete failure I agree with you this
is a technical failure absolutely this
is a creative failure
but I don't think that it's a full
failure because as you said something
that's true the the greatest sin of film
can be is be boring the greatest sin of
film can be is just be nothing and if it
was truly a bad film we wouldn't be
talking about it right technically yeah
I mean like on paper it checks all the
boxes for the worst movie ever made and
you know we're not defending this film
it's clearly bad I mean in every way
it's just I'm very kind of interested in
the whole notion that why is it that so
many there's so many other YouTube
channels too dedicated to talking about
bad movies and just discussing bad film
look like RiffTrax and as we already
mentioned Mystery Science Theater there
is a fascination with this that is
unending and it's not just pointing your
finger and laughing it's not just that
there is a very perverse fascination
that I have with films like this that
make me want to watch them let's talk
about the 60 cuts to the photograph or
the painting oh my god the painting I
feel like that was put in just because
all right we need to really build up the
tension we just need to cut back and
forth and back and forth and back and
forth nobody says anything no it's just
like it go it gets it was funny and then
it still funny because it keeps going to
come that it gets to that oh no they're
still going they're still looking at
this this fucking painting I think he
just thought it was a lot more
frightening than it is he was like this
is so scary I paid $5.00 for somebody to
paint this a portrait
I doubt he even paid anybody that it
sounds like he paid most of the people
in the film with shares yeah the profits
yeah so arguably if that's valid no one
got paid no money so in that case you
could say this is not really a
professional film because no one made
any money it's an art film it's just
some attempt student it's a student film
it's a yeah it's a thing that exists
talking about that painting the actor
who portrays you know I
honestly I don't remember his name or
even if they even said it he doesn't
speak for the first half of the entire
film for the first half of the movie
he's lying on a slab just sleeping I
guess while his wives or concubines or
whatever they are just stand there with
their eyes closed do I get lines yet not
yet just stand there
later you'll fight in a really really
long fake looking fight where you all
just roll on top of each other and then
one of you will get slapped mercilessly
so she's dead
slapped to death Jesus Christ
[Music]
one thing that's really interesting
about the times we live in right now is
for a guy like that who I'm just gonna
go make a movie I don't need any
professional equipment I'll need any
professional actors I'm just gonna go
and do something and right now we're at
a time where anyone can make a movie and
maybe not a full movie at a professional
movie but you can go out with a pretty
decent camera and you can just go hey
I'm gonna go film something scary I'm
gonna go do something with my friends
and there are so many opportunities for
creating your own work you know to show
up I always think of my favorite example
of that is the short film that inspired
lights out David F Sandberg yeah which
is just as something as simple as hey
wouldn't it be cool if you just when you
flip a light switch on and off something
just gets closer to you with every bit
of darkness just that one little concept
got him the feature and now he's doing
Shazam you did the Annabelle movie which
was way better than the first one
absolutely yeah and I really like lights
out yeah I went back so - yeah I think
that stuff like this you there's so much
to look at from a creative standpoint
going yes it's terrible yes there's so
much more he could have done with it but
there's still so much to learn from it
and we're looking 50 years 30 years
later and we're still able to just go
hey I'm you think of that opportunity
and what he did and just look at what we
could do so much better now there's no
excuse to make something this bad bad
exactly I mean everyone's got a camera
in their pocket a thousand times better
than the one that they were using for
instance since and access to computers
or your friend probably has a computer
you know that will allow you to cut it
together better than this one and there
really is no excuse anymore to not try
to go out and make something and it's
funny how a film like this can actually
get us to this level of craft discussion
and stuff like is the shittiest movie
ever fucking made and we're sitting here
talking but it's true though like you're
absolutely right there is no real excuse
anymore to not try and despite the fact
this is the only thing this guy ever did
in regards to movies he did get it made
anyone could put a film on YouTube now
there's no reason that if you love film
and you want to be a storyteller you
need to start somewhere we almost have
to start somewhere and we're in a really
great place right now where you can do
whatever you want to do if you could if
you build something that you have the
capacity to build like this guy should
have done something in one room yes with
like two actors who don't speak mm-hmm
and you know this is where the problems
come in it's when you true story that
was the same he wanted to make a massive
plan 9 from outer space Syfy
extravaganza and he had not the money
for it but he wanted to do that big
thing and a lot of indie filmmakers make
that mistake instead of wanting to do
something small-scale with a small
budget they want to make the Spielberg
movie they want to make the George Lucas
movie but they don't have that budget
yet here so you're totally right that's
they want to start school as a freshman
and then jump right into a you know yeah
CEO fortune 500 company mm-hmm you know
you have to start with your capabilities
you have to give yourself room to grow
and to hone your skills and to find out
what you're really good at yeah I mean
this guy could have been great at some
other form of storytelling this was not
it clearly he has some form of Drive or
he wouldn't have put in the time and
effort to do this right that's something
I also love about the industry though
because we all are coming from the same
place we love film we love movies we
love these big impassioned visual forms
that make us feel something right
whether that's fear or joy or humor
whatever it is and we're all coming from
that place you you very rarely are gonna
get something hey fuckin hate movies man
this is socks I'm gonna talk about
movies for the rest of my life even
though I hate it
why am I doing this it doesn't happen
not so much no no so when I see a movie
like this it makes me think there is no
excuse that it's just a moment there's
no excuse get your outside get your ass
out there build something for yourself
find out what you want to make and go
make it can I be honest with you when we
sat down to record
this review I was positive we would
spend most of this video laughing at the
stupid shit in this movie that was maybe
the most inspiring shit I have ever
heard in my life because of Manos the
hands fuck fucking faith I am so pumped
right now I want to go write 10 fucking
screenplays I want to direct 10 movies
and I want to dedicate them all to you
because that was fucking inspiring a
shit on a serious note though I
completely agree when you see films made
at this level and you recognize that
this was done in the 1960s and yet it
was still released and and I talked
about the Evil Dead with our buddy Rob
and you know that was Sam Raimi aged
like 20 or something just doing it and
and that's the type of thing where it's
like yeah Manos sucks okay it's fucking
terrible it's a piece of shit I mean
it's atrocious on every level this isn't
anything people haven't heard before but
it's the it's just that drive that
people like him and why so you know had
where they're like I don't care what the
world says I'm doing it and that even
though you look at this movie and you're
like that's what I definitely don't want
to do there is something to say about
the fact that it exists and that the
drive he had got it made and you're
right we have no excuse anymore we have
no excuse if you're out there and you
want to make a movie just do it just
start working on it today like literally
start working on it today there's
nothing that's gonna stop you from from
creating something in your head just
take the time to take the time you need
to build something that's unique that's
you that only you could make you know
too many people are trying to do what
other people have done we all have
something to say and the faster you
realize okay sittin on sittin on butts
not getting anything done you know I
know what it is hearing what I have to
say then find a way find a story find a
format that lets you say what you want
to say I agree and I just want to spread
my arms out to you and and thank Manos
the hands of fate for this incredibly
inspiring discussion about being
creative and trying to make something
even if the odds are against you you are
the best man
Thank You Joe package you sir yes guys
thank you so much as always for watching
obviously Manos you know go see it it'll
inspire you that's the point
go see Manos the hands of fate it will
infect you with the desire to make
something better than that
seriously though Joe you're an amazing
writer and I'm lucky to have you as a
friend so thank you very much for
joining me on this video I'd like to do
more videos like this with my friends I
think it's a really fun way to have a
discussion about movies that I can't
really do by myself in a room which can
get you know a little tedious sometimes
so it's nice to have somebody to talk to
instead of blue wall you know it's great
so I thank you very much and guys look
forward to more very soon as always did
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck minimized do those fucking
dude that was great
[Music]